hike through history and take the family
on a date with dates in this week's
vegas drives las vegas now's rocky theas
adventures to tacopa california to
explore the china ranch day farm and
bakery
so we are amongst the original trees
right of the china ranch state farm tell
us the history behind the trees uh well
rocky these trees were planted about a
hundred years ago from seed
from a mail order catalog actually
and the people living here at the time
just
threw them out by hand
there was no
real spacing they just scattered and
grew like this and that's why they grew
kind of abstract like this
they did yes and and they nobody tended
to them for about 50 years so they um
found water on their own and because
this is considered an oasis we are a
real
deal desert oasis we're looking up at
the dates right now how many are you
producing roughly i would say 40 000
pounds of a year we're processing we
have about 15 different varieties here
some of them are
hybrids that only grow here and then
other ones be brought in from
other areas like iraq
morocco
and north africa so you know most states
are native to the middle east so we
harvest dates in the fall and winter
months that's about half the year we're
harvesting
and then in the springtime we're
pollinating and then the summer
is when everything ripens they need
about
90 days of 100 degree temperature or
higher so you're a great place so we
just took our uh date date to the next
level okay we are in the lift kayla tell
us what your job here is on the farm so
i am actually the field manager i have
everything to do with the dates from
pollinating to tying down and bagging
them all the way up until harvest
currently we are in the tying down phase
which means that we take one of the
bundles and we actually tie it to one of
these branches with a piece of twine
that way it doesn't break under its own
weight there's actually five different
stages to a date right now we're in the
calal phase which is the third phase so
right now they will start to turn yellow
you can kind of see one here it's
starting to get a little bit of color on
it that is actually the sugars and the
dates starting to produce
and then that will start to become more
of a sweet little fruit it will soften
next and become chewy and that's when
you get the last final stage being the
tomato
i like the tamir stage yeah it's my
favorite chips
what is your favorite way to eat a date
plain and cold that's the way to go
we're in a smoothie smoothies are really
really good to eat a date i have one
every single day speaking of dates
smoothies i think that's where we're
headed now yes i just had this morning
[Music]
with the smoothie we start with some ice
and a frozen banana
do two scoops of
escape paste here
and then let's see we'll do some cashews
this is a mesquite flour dairy free
there's a nice smoothie right there
[Music]
wow
oh my gosh this is so good
it's not too sweet
it's just perfect yeah i think it's good
i think it's great i think don't be
modest this is great
that does look great wow and healthy
yeah totally all right